so you just you just so let me ask you
say during the pandemic obviously
i probably think i know the answer but
what did you do during that
well
right when it was starting yeah
i bumped into dr oz
this is so weird right it's like oh
maybe like
february 25th or something right around
there or was it a random thing just on a
like a studio lot oh wow like this the
the sony lot
yeah were you i know who doctor ozzie
nobody's borderline quacky okay all
right he you know yeah i'm sure he's a
decent human being with ethics and my
story is based on him being the best
doctor in the history
[Laughter]
that contradicts
i don't know what you're talking about
wacky business all right so he's the
great the greatest doctor i live in the
best doctor
and
i'm like
let me think of this covid thing yeah
and he's like you know judd it's just
it's so contagious
and they're going to try to like
slow it down and stop it but a million
people are going to die and we'll all
know one of them
oh wow so correct that's and it was all
correct yeah thus
the greatest greatest
wow i take it all back would that scare
the [ __ ] out of you it did because i was
about to go to south by southwest to
show the king of staten island
and we were all like can we go
i think we can go i think right we can
go
and uh it was like uh my wife's birthday
and we had a trip and we were gonna go
to some spa for her birthday and this
was like the first week of march and we
were like
you could still go to new mexico right
it's like yeah i don't think it's there
yet and we did we went away for like
four or five days oh wow on the tv every
night it was getting worse and worse
until it was really bad and we're like
in our bathrobes at a spa
getting massages and we're like i don't
think we're supposed to let people touch
us wow like people are really rubbing on
us right now yeah yeah and then we got
home and you know went in the house and
locked the door for a year
right we had tom hanks gotten it by then
it was the week i think yeah because
that's when it became real for me yeah
tummy hanks got it yeah holy [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] you know i mean like tom hanks is
america's dad and he's careful yeah he's
like seems like a mindful guy he's a
careful person yeah
and then we went in the house
and then in the beginning of the house
what i realized was
that my family
wasn't that concerned about my health
you know like they were a little looser
than i was and i'm like i'm the oldest
one i'm the one who dies i'm the one who
dies yeah yeah and uh they you know
we're a little looser with
some of some of the rules i'm like
rubbing on these [ __ ] amazon packages
like purell
aren't you mad that we did that for no
reason like at some point we realized
it's not on the packages but after like
eight months of package rubbing yeah i
had the amount of burns the chemical
burns on my hands i i bought the uv
lights yeah every inch of it i would do
it on his body when he would come back
from
11. we went to like a craft store right
at the beginning right so like
we were aware like i think we're going
to be in the house for like months and
months and months so i go with you know
my my two daughters and we go let's go
to like what's that craft store with
michael's or michael's yes we're like
let's go to michael's i think we need
crafts like we're gonna do a lot of
crafts for the next few months let's go
buy like feathers and blue and stuff so
we're in there and this store is
enormous and there's like 16 people in
it but to us each one of them
100 had it
and oh wow we were just walking through
like like we were in space like
scared of the cashier yeah and then we
went in in the house and then i had to
promote the movie on my couch oh my god
for like two months interviews all day
and those are the worst those are the
worst kinds like i'd rather be in
wouldn't you rather be in person yeah
but there were some moments where you're
like it's nice to sit here
when you're doing like craig you know
like crazy amounts of of interviews like
around the world and oh yeah like oh
it's nice that because they have that
day where you you get that list of like
times
that's the worst day of anyone's life
yeah because it goes from like
6 a.m to like 11 and it's just these all
these numbers you have to call and
they're six minutes each yeah sometimes
they put you on they just keep sending
people in
and people don't understand that people
like say will smith like twice a year
three times a year he has to sit in room